let's talk just briefly a few more
minutes about Kerry Lake Kerry Lake came
up with a story that no one in my
audience seems to believe and I don't
know that I believe either Kerry Lake
recently came out and said
someone came to my house the other day
and they offered me a ton of money and a
cushy job if I leave politics and just
get out of politics and she says it was
someone known to her now of course as
soon as I heard this story I thought to
myself she's a loser so far why would
anyone pay her to get out of politics
when she just loses
um she went on the Charlie Kirk show
yesterday using this very very intense
camera filter very very soft Focus
filter that she loves and she elaborated
on the story it won't surprise you that
she isn't naming the people or person
that allegedly did this let's take a
listen and see if any of it sounds
believable
here we go you were offered money almost
a bribe from powerful people to leave
politics
tell us about that yeah yeah well you
know I was on your show I don't know a
couple weeks ago and you asked me about
uh a run for Senate rumors were swirling
and I had I told you look you know
dozens of people at this point but
thousands of people have reached out
saying you gotta run for Senate if if
things don't work in the courts you've
got to run for Senate and I said look my
priority is this the governor's office
the race that we won and our case but if
things don't go right well then I'm not
going to get out of politics because I'm
not going to let the same people who
stole this election take our movement
away and silence us so I would consider
that I told you that on your show and
that made some headlines and that
worried a lot of people and on Tuesday
of last week as I was kind of getting
myself ready to go to CPAC I had a a
visitor at my door uh and somebody I
know invited the person in and uh they
started with an offer for a a fancy job
title a nice salary a position on a
board if I would just agree to not run
for Senate to not be on the ballot to
just stay out of politics kind of park
it for two years to which I laughed I
said are you kidding me uh I think you
do know that I walked away from a
prestigious job and a big paycheck I'm
not motivated by that and conversation
went on and as I finally moved this
person kind of out of my house and said
I've got things to do no thank you it
moved into well what what do you want to
make this happen we want you out there's
some powerful people back East who
really want you out back East they they
know that I will win in a primary and
I'll frankly win in the general election
as well now a lot of the story I mean
listen there's a lot here that doesn't
make any sense first of all why would
someone who lost be seen as such a
threat that they need to pay her to get
out well you could make the argument the
strongest argument would be that
Republicans so she says this is someone
known to her she doesn't say whether
it's a left Winger or a right wing or
you could argue Republicans want her out
because they wrongly think she will hurt
them and of course she's like no I don't
hurt people I mean I won and I won the
governor's race even though they they
stole it and I would win the senate race
if I do that so Republicans are just
wrong for wanting me out the other
argument would be Republicans want me
out because they are rhinos they they I
they don't want my type of Republic
because Republican to run they want
someone who is you know like a Mitt
Romney Paul Ryan or whatever
Democrats would want her out because
they see her as such a threat to them
you know we Democrats need to pay Carey
Lake to get her out of the race because
she would defeat whoever is the eventual
Democratic nominee none of it seems very
plausible I have to tell you pretty
concerned they want to put out their
typical candidates and so the the
conversation turned to what what would
it be what would your price be what's
your price well my price is I want our
actions to be run smoothly and I want to
be in the governor's office now of
course this is idiotic not only because
it's really hard to believe but the
truth is you know that deep down Carrie
Lake although she wants to pretend you
can't buy her out if the money was right
of course she would do it right I mean
it's like listen Carrie you lost
you can run for Senate you can run
around and do the campaign and the
entire thing you might lose again or
here's some meaningful amount of money
for you if the money was right she would
of course accept it so it's possible the
story is completely made up it's
possible that it wasn't enough money or
it's possible that really what Kerry
Lake wants is to be Trump's VP we know
that on some level that's something she
wants to do but the story as she is
telling it has so many holes in it it's
like a Swiss cheese where I belong and I
said there is no price there's no price
that you could pay which is of course a
lie to make me go away or the people of
Arizona go away we're going to continue
to fight so I wouldn't take a hundred I
wouldn't take a million I wouldn't take
10 million I wouldn't take 100 million
she would take 10 million that's how
important this fight is that we're in
right now Charlie yeah so listen I I'm
curious whether people in my audience
believe this story obviously she's uh
you know the the weird thing about not
saying who it was is if you're truly
disgusted with someone making this offer
why wouldn't you name them in other
words why are you trying to protect
someone that you see as a deplorable
person making you a disgusting offer
that you would never accept why wouldn't
you expose that they offered this to you
the second part of it is these stories
do have an air of the Trump serve
routines you know they came to me they
said sir and like the stories are very
often made up or at least
extraordinarily distorted three as I as
I'm saying it doesn't seem plausible
based on the facts and then the other
part of it is the emphasis on a run for
Senate from Kerry Lake
she seems to be continuing to say I'm
eventually going to be the governor
because they're going to reinstate me or
end State me I guess it would be so then
why would she be talking about the
Senate anyway as the focus from these
other people if she's really going to be
reinstated like I know you're saying but
David she's not going to be in stated
Governor I know that but if we're
supposed to believe she believes it then
why is she even talking about running
for the Senate she'd be too busy being
Governor it's all insane and my question
to you is do you believe this story do
you think this happened or any version
of this happened or is it being invented
and contrived completely from the ground
up by Carrie Lake let me know in the
comments email in send a tweet however
you want to get in touch uh curious to
see what folks in the audience think